[Applause]
well welcome back i hope everybody had a
pretty decent three-day weekend
but we still got to do the news
so following last week's mass shooting
30 more people were killed over the
weekend
13 in philly alone
residents are now safer at bill cosby's
house
[Laughter]
so to tackle issues like mass shootings
and this is nightly murder
i think we should go to the very
beginning
you know our cosmos are 13.8 billion
years old
bet you didn't think i meant literally
the beginning but i figured we'll start
there and then by my estimate we should
be done with this monologue by the time
william devane runs out of gold
[Laughter]
but to see what evil looks like now it
helps to see it with a backdrop of
history it might tell us what we went
wrong in this blink of an eye of the
last 30 years because something did
sure we've had horrible violence for
centuries genghis khan killed millions
of people but he also fathered a ton
historians call him that year as pete
hegsith
that's a joke imagine the father's day
cards when genghis was around huh
dear dad you conquered my heart and asia
minor
ivan the terrible he didn't get that
nickname from not spraying febreze after
he used the bathroom
he was truly terrible
glad they're not around to hear me
riffing on him
[Laughter]
and then there are the world wars
one which i guess led to two
i bet you didn't think i'd be this
thorough did you
i'm a regular julia socrates
the good news it seems we're less
violent as a species except for these
spasms of mayhem and this ongoing murder
spree or as george gascon calls it
misdemeanors
but guns have been around longer than
wolf blitzer or even joy behar
but not mass shootings they're new
kids used to bring guns to school back
in the day apparently true teachers pets
brought apples so other students could
shoot them off the teacher's heads
i made that up
but we've had violence weaponry and evil
and that's just the gutfeld family
but this latest violence seems new in
this greater context why is that well
guns scream the left but guns have been
around
too but it's that single variable
thinking again
right whoopee
listen this
ar-15's got to go i'm sorry and i don't
care nra
you got to give that gun up you can have
your other yeehaw guns whatever you want
the ar-15 has to go is not a hunting gun
it is not a gun where you're gonna go
out and shoot your dinner
this gun is meant to kill people
that's what it's for and you can't have
it anymore
well as long as i get to keep my yeehaw
guns
gonna go out and shoot me some yeehaws
anyway she sold me
but now there's another new variable
that could be part of this bullying
feels like that's gotten worse and our
solutions for bullying seem pretty weak
pushing pronouns and colorful flags
something tells me that's not addressing
the people most likely to kill
real outcasts don't fit a trendy label
meanwhile the schools have been in
perpetual decline for decades as costs
go up kids would call it a pyramid
scheme if they knew what pyramids are
and they're really damaged kids are just
too young to have a paper trail that
might serve as a red flag when they try
to get a weapon
so what about broken homes that's new as
well since the 1970s we've seen society
accept the decline of the family some
have actually even encouraged it
and what fills those gaps well you can
have gangs video games tick tock
it's much like biden's energy policy
we're going to force you off fossil
fuels with no real alternative
because the decline of the nuclear
family is a loss of precious energy too
when things go bad for a kid what's he
got to rely on god are the mom and dad
and brothers and sisters that served as
a hedge against isolation so he's got an
empty tank and what's he fill it with
some seriously bad
so those are the variables family
decline social media alienation
loneliness and they intersect to create
both the nightly mayhem and mass
shootings these variables can't be
observed by the media or the left
because they're culpable it's like a
vampire looking into a mirror who can't
see his reflection
true they've wrecked more homes than
hurricane katrina
see with no father in the house how does
a young man learn how to handle his own
rage sometimes he doesn't
and of and all of this violence could
reflect this vital inability to handle
disagreements in a civil manner civility
becomes the opposite of manliness
meanwhile something else has arisen in
the last four decades cable news where
actions are amplified beyond anyone's
imagination you could be ivan the
terrible in one quick and easy step and
the media obliges by making you a
household name and after all isn't that
what the youth of america want fame and
fortune at any cost
yet we blame the carnage on whatever is
used in the crime no one dare work
backwards but you know i'm old enough to
remember when democrats cared about root
causes
but now who has the time hell who wants
to make that effort i mean it's only
this country's future that's being
gunned down it's much easier to just
blame that object in the killer's hand
but the last 30 years show you it's more
than that a broken household contains a
creates a broken person sent to a broken
untrained and ambivalent school and
commits a hellish act amplified by a
broken media
every action incentivized the criminal
gets back at the broken home the crime
makes the forgettable teen unforgettable
and the media turns it into content
the killers don't even have to make a
demand
so sure we can raise the rifle ban to
21. that works so well with
alcohol but until we admit that the
problem is multifaceted we're lost it's
everything our modern culture mocked
family religion even fathers and that
turned out to matter more than anyone
admitted when you have no purpose and
you don't respect life or fear death and
now a thoughtless culture blames the gun
rather than their own desertion of
values
i guess i can't blame them
but i do
completely
let's
she talks so fast your ears have to put
on track shoes outnumbered co-host emily
compagno
he works in the hottest clubs on the
comedy circuit offering men paper towels
in the bathroom
actor writer and comedian jamie lisao
he's what you get when you cross an 80s
teen villain with the state of
connecticut
it's true co-host of the clay travis at
bucks extent show buck sexy
[Music]
and she can refinish furniture with her
laugh
fox news contributor cat tip
emily good to see you uh you were one of
the only people here at the office
yesterday i was holding down the fort
yeah you're welcome that's another sign
for saying i was very lonely
a very lonely person they have free food
when you work here on mondays don't they
no they don't i was eating chips out of
the free baskets that's it no they have
free snacks they have free food they
just didn't tell you
we all enjoyed it we actually came back
here and took some home uh so what do
you we're now in that second step where
now it's like we must do something we
must do something and then you see that
there's only one variable that like the
politicians will look at which almost
guarantees failure because we don't
trust them if you're only looking at one
variable which is guns no one else will
trust you you have to look at everything
else what do you say to that it
guarantees failure and it also to me
illuminates um
why it's all just politics to begin with
so let's take chicago which you brought
up in the intro
illinois has one of the strictest gun
laws
in the country right and yet chicago saw
43 people shot this weekend eight of
them fatally and that mayor was the
first among the first to come out after
the uvalde shooting to say oh we need
these stricter gun laws but if they
really cared about that vulnerable
community if they really cared about
youth's lives being lost to guns and
it's clearly not
those laws that are being passed right
they're calling for red flag laws
they're calling for heightened
background checks do you think that has
any type of impact on the recidivists on
the gangbangers on those communities
that are actually um the the that are
actually responsible for these continued
homicides not at all it's a totally
separate problem and i know that's just
one piece of that larger pie that you
talked about for sure but in terms of
the of that homicide criminal justice
realm it would do a lot better for them
to enforce the laws that we already have
rather than create random ones that have
zero applicability to who's actually
pulling the trigger on the streets that
is a very good point they never
the laws are already there
people will argue against that that the
reason why chica that it's it's you have
the logic in reverse that chicago has
the strictest gun laws because of the
crime that's what they'll argue but that
but uh those people what do they care
huh jamie
yeah
it's always good to be a comedian when
we start off on gun crime
whatever whatever joke you're about to
make just remember i have so many jokes
about
gun violence yes um
it's just which one to choose yeah
there's so many of them
and i encourage you just to just
workshop all of them yeah right and ruin
your career you can see them all in my
new special things that aren't funny yes
dude what about whoopi going like hey
nra hey anna i was watching it like what
are the chances the nra is hearing this
message
and what
what are the chances anyone's watching
that show yes
let alone it's that was like so crazy i
think i'm going to go be controversial i
think they should raise the age to 21
for all the yeehaw weapons the hot water
and um
i don't i honestly think they should
make it 21 and just see what happens
yeah like a test i think it's i'm always
for beta testing anything you know but
yes the hard thing about testing
something like this
is because even though these mass
shootings are not rare enough they are
rare enough that you could do an
experiment for five years and not get a
mass shooting and it might not have
anything to do with what you're testing
for sure that's 100 sure and like some
places have weird laws again alaska yeah
for guns like the background check
they facetime you and just look in the
background
[Applause]
that's not very
that actually might work that's true
work
you see like a
that's looking in the background you're
right like you see a bong and like yeah
but no but like the the kid the mass
shooter from apparently he killed cats
he had a bag of cats how did we miss
this
anybody who mutilates animals always
ends up moving to the next level right
like my uncle steve
yeah i know i know i know
where am i i'm gonna go to you buck good
to see you as always you always bring a
thoughtful uh kind of veneer to even the
most drawl topics so i
i don't even know what i would i'll take
it but it's been a long weekend
been a very long weekend part of my
brain i think i left somewhere but i'm
not sure where so i had never been to
chicago before and so i went a couple of
weeks ago and i was standing this is
this is all true standing in front of
it's the like the bean it looks like a
metallic spleen everyone goes to see
this thing and it's just this big metal
thing and everyone stares and they go oh
my gosh and i turned to my girlfriend
and i said maybe the crime in this city
beautiful day in chicago maybe the crime
in this city really is just limited to
certain areas there are some cities
where it's very new york for example gun
violence is very much precinct precinct
precinct in a few places and then there
was a fatal shooting at the bean that
then caused a total lockdown on anyone
under uh under the age of 18 being even
allowed in the park two hours after we
were there so clearly chicago has a
really big problem along with a lot of
other cities now we get to the root
causes issue we can talk about blm and a
lot of things i'll just point this out
while people are discussing the gun law
changes that would be possible gun laws
disproportionately affect young minority
men in major cities they're the ones who
disproportionately get arrested for it
so what you see is on the one hand
they're saying magazine limitations like
justin trudeau they're saying more
background checks but then the district
attorney's in los angeles in
philadelphia they have young guys they
say well i don't want to i don't want to
actually enforce the law against him
it's a felony he's not going to be able
to vote he's not such a tremendous point
and so this is what ends up happening
they make it harder for people to use
the yeehaw guns at the range they have
the state trooper come by and say do you
have seven rounds in that magazine or
five but then at the city level where
the violence is actually happening they
say well we don't want to really enforce
these strict gun laws that strictly
because we're going to have a disparate
impact and social justice will suffer so
they don't even know what they're trying
to do that is such an
uh disturbing and correct point
so that's he just answered why they're
not enforcing the laws there you go see
what do you think cat last word to you i
i don't know i just think that when we
talk about do something when people say
let's do something that's not an actual
call to action that's that's really not
doing anything people even they want to
talk about want to ban these weapons
even if that was in place if you talk
about this most recent shooting that
wouldn't have made much of a difference
if the cops are just hanging out outside
the school for more than an hour
and obviously like you said most of the
gun violence that occurs is not these
sort of mass shootings that we see and i
think that we need to be really careful
about making laws from a place of
emotion in general
and i think that it's one thing to say
you're pro-second amendment or you're
against second amendment but to me the
second amendment is the argument
because that's in place
and that applies and if you don't
respect that then really the whole
constitution you can't respect because
if all of them don't matter that none of
them do yeah
by the way
it's very easy for canada to like do
that gun ban when your next-door
neighbor is the united states right
right it's like oh my god there's let's
let's go next door bang on the door and
see if they got any guns and we always
do this is a family tradition up there
by the way trudeau's dad the prime
minister what back in like the 70s he
also made it basically impossible to get
a handgun there in the first place so
now his son comes along and for just the
purposes of a little virtue signaling
and getting some media attention from
the libs in this country says you can't
get you basically can't get a handgun in
canada anyway yeah okay
perhaps the dumbest person in canada
became the prime minister you know who
can get handguns though
[Applause]
the criminals that are shooting people
in canada which is not happening the
same numbers it does here but they can
get handguns yeah but people that want
to obey the law can't get him they can't
that's how it works out all right
nonsense up next are biden's aides
throwing him under the bus because he
makes an incoherent fuss hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else